here is the views ana navarro and ana
navarro was on cnn somehow the woman is
on the view and on cnn i mean what deal
with the devil she made i have no idea
uh but she basically wants to kill a
couple of her autistic family members
the mother before during and after the
child and i have not anybody could tell
you what you need to do with your life
or with your uterus and because i have a
family with a lot of special needs kids
i have a brother who's 57 and has the
mental and motive skills of a
one-year-old and i know what that means
financially emotionally physically for a
family and i know not all families can
do it and i have a step granddaughter
who was born with a down syndrome and
you know what it is very difficult in
florida to get services it is not as
easy as it sounds on paper and i've got
another another step grandson who is a
very autistic who has autism and it is
incredible and their mothers and people
who are in that society who are in that
community will tell you that they've
considered suicide because that's how
difficult it is to get help because
that's how lonely they could go because
they can't get other jobs because they
have financial issues because the care
that they're able to give their other
children
suffers and so why can i be catholic and
still think this is a wrong decision
because i'm american
i'm catholic inside the church i'm
catholic when it comes to me but there's
a lot of americans who are not catholic
and are not christian and are not
baptist and you have no damn right to
tell them what they should do with their
body nobody does
there's so much there it's like
okay so first off again the irony of
these people this is the same psycho
lunatic who would sit at that table with
those harpies of the view for the last
two years demanding that you get
injected some with something an
experimental vaccine or you get fired so
her argument about my body my that's all
just complete nonsense and [ __ ]
secondly um we can have an honest
discussion about what sort of uh
benefits there should be at the state
level or federal level or whatever for
children with special needs and whether
that should be done through private
charities or some level uh through the
government and again whether that's
federal or state or whatever that might
be but in essence what she's saying
there is oh i've got these kids in my
family and we should have aborted them
and i'm pretty sure she's not getting
invited to christmas as michael just
pointed out while we were watching that
because i have no doubt that the mothers
of those children the fathers of those
children whether they're autistic or
whatever else they have or or for the
well not many people watch cnn but for
anyone who has an autistic child or a
child with with other developmental
disabilities or whatever it might be as
as hard as that is and everyone's
entitled to making their own choices in
life and figuring out how to do things
and again whether it's public funding on
these things or private funding on these
things or whatever it's like basically
she just said we should have aborted
them that that is in essence what she
just said they'd be better off dead than
alive
so that's anna navarro's take on that uh
and it gets worse it gets worse these
people are completely out of control
here's democrat representative jackie
speer
with a bit of a call for his direction
there is a war out there and we need to
recognize that we've got to armor up
that's right this is not a drill
there's a war armor up remember lori
lightfoot a couple weeks ago call to
arms i mean they can do all of the
things that they purported uh donald
trump to do uh but do not worry as the
war comes as this handmaid's tale
unfolds right in front of us new york
attorney general leticia james she gonna
fund the abortion so you can go to new
york kill a baby and then go over to
coney island and get on the roller
coaster
we've established a fund in the state of
new york to pay for individuals
traveling to new york to seek abortions
for lodging for daycare this is a state
that respects the right of women to
choose
guess what
i'm actually okay with this i i actually
am okay with this i believe in states
rights so if new york wants to become a
haven
for abortions if california wants to
become a haven for abortions if people
in new york want their tax dollars to go
so that low-income uh black
girls in alabama can travel there to
have their babies aborted
and then you know maybe you get like i
don't know you get like a coupon for ice
cream or something while you're there if
that's what new york
uh residents want their tax dollars to
go to that is democracy and it's messy
that's how it works so okay you have to
decide if you live in new york and you
are governed by these people if if
that's something you're okay with your
dollars paying for but that is
federalism so federalism you know
sometimes they're going to do things in
states that maybe you're not that
thrilled with as i've said a couple
times i suspect after new york and
california become these abortion havens
and they keep busing in truckloads of
usually low-income black and brown girls
to have abortions i'm guessing the
optics of it after about six months are
going to look pretty bad when the
numbers start coming in and people
realize boy they've aborted something
like 10x the amount of black babies as
uh as white babies then then they're
gonna have a real problem on their hands
you